so keeping the vision computation jockey
on my name is Daniel Rockets Reynolds
from buffett public schools how it's
going to start as i'm going to talk for
about I'll watch the time I'll talk for
about 10 minutes and do a demo for about
a minute and then Tom will talk for ten
minutes you know keeping the vision is
kind of standing on the shoulders of
giants it's kind of a thing people say a
lot you know Stephen Wolfram and I'm
treating data you can tweet a lot of
different types of through functional
programming a lot of different types of
math is equivalent that's something
we're very trying to make use of and
also people like on these are just a
bunch of the books that I used computer
simulation you know modeling nature
Mathematica guy book this guy michael
trot in his book um onam graphical and
all that you know this book by Tom
Wickham Jones was a big influences of
about 20 year old book but you see it's
a pretty tripping on colorful color and
it made me think I'm you know get kids
enthused you know Eric vice dean and his
on his work on cataloging mathematics
and all these people a lot of people who
influenced me and I want to share that
and that's keeping the vision it's a
play on words division of those people
but also visualization in general that's
that's a theme ok I'm straight out a
computation so imagine CJ being able to
DJ any form of data as a form of
expression for the modern age like
mathematical landscapes or you could
even put fish populations if you're
playing the UM fish market or something
as a DJ you could um Stephen Wolfram
talks a lot about alien artifacts and
we're saying this it looks like I only
an artifact because it's so cumbersome
but on you know hip-hop culture has been
around for over 40 years and it's a way
to try and get youth broken glass
everywhere people pissing on the
sidewalk like they just don't care from
Grandmaster Flash you know that's the
situation a lot of students i work with
live in i work with on mostly on
immigrant and refugee students in inner
city as well as on predominantly
african-american population and a lot of
low-income students and we just want to
find a way to get you know the stuff
computation in the people's heads and
i'm a lot of people see things in their
heads people
city and kids and things and it's a good
way to give them creative ways instead
of getting in trouble all time teaching
about computation on visualization
influences on me here's I'm Toccata and
Fugue from walt disney's of
visualization um here's a guy John
Whitney his experiments in the 60s you
can see him on a computer doing
visualization we got Jeff's an airplane
from nineteen sixty-nine with a liquid
light show and a lot of artists that
influenced me that use geometric stuff
Ashley Kandinsky Juan moro Miro and on
and we got man ray and then here you
know I was a big influence on Bill
Thurston's a big influence to me here's
the not not hyperbolic geometry I'm you
know a sure got me in a hyperbolic
geometry when I continue with Thurston
so we cannot continue this is on my own
drawings of the type of manifold they've
always kind of scene in my head and
stuff when I close my eyes and stuff
like that I've always sort of scene
objects and shapes and things so I've
got like hundreds of little drawings
like this that I do you know just some
ideas and I want to DJ landscapes like
this and kids could do that too as well
as other types of math so continue here
are some things I'm interested in my
icon we c z2 the second plus C for the
demand abroad and here we've got
Mandelbrot Z to the third plus C but if
you put in Z 2 2.5 plus c you get
something that's transitioning kind of
smoothly if I may let me use the term
right but so let's take the Z 2 2.5 plus
C and here Z 2 2.5 plus C to the second
because this is C to the one because the
exponent is unexpressed here and then
here Z 2 2.5 plus c2 a 2.5 you can see
and sometimes those type in like Z to
the five over PI or something you know I
mean I'll get all different types of
ways to extend the Mandelbrot and I'd
like to you know do things in
Mathematica we're still working on but
being able to move through like all like
tons of dimensions you know off by
putting pressing buttons on controllers
and adding things to the Mandelbrot to
move and turning knobs and go around the
landscapes I'm types of devices on today
we're going to show you KAOSS pad and k
oscillator decima XY grid
then we have SL for a turntable unit
we're trying to a lot of Fourier
transform to send it and on wavelet
stuff but we don't have it in directing
it without matica yet but what we do
have is a Kaos later but I'm going to do
something with stephen wolfram on there
and on we use apc40 control board we
don't have with us so at SCB 10 10 4
controller just because we're trying to
keep it simple to take a little bit
longer to set up if you brought
everything we also trying to put EEG
sensors so we're djing all the data our
brains could be tripping out and send in
like signals to and just we could be
trying to control it even on body
sensors you could get our heart going
and that could be pulsing in
visualizations instruments and
microphones if we had a whole band
drummer and everything's moving around
on the screen microscopes um you know
and wealth all the new image processing
stuff and 11 it's really with
mathematical 11 that these dreams are
probably going to become more into
fruition just because it's so much more
thumb signal processing liquid light
shows and video mixers and stuff we'd
really like to UM do things for parties
at like gravitational wave detectors
like like oh I vote uh um you know and I
wrote to end ago one time in India and
that's what I could go DJ some of this
stuff um II Lisa which is coming up and
bicep to all these gravitational wave
detectors particle colliders like LHC
they might build a super collider in
Beijing um I read a lot of their
particle flow algorithm pre documents
and stuff on slack and Rick and the
older stuff um neutrino detectors like
super-kamiokande and all that you know
sky surveys you could get the stuff um
you know you can put w map and plunk
isn't up there but you could on also get
Kepler and maybe we could take the arm
like all of the analysis that you're
doing of the stellar objects and load
them is objects like you could load up
the horsehead nebula or something and
get like streaming data of it and in
your DJ simulations you could
gravitational waves they have the sound
if you like when they are made of the
recent detection you could load it as a
sample like huge while you're like
scratching that'd be a good idea I think
um and then education we're trying to
build something where you can do your
whole content with DJ controls like if
you have a PDF you could just press a
button
and then you could use a turntable shoot
a turntable ahead it would move the PDF
page forward or pull it backwards we
want to go to document or a physical
simulation if you had like a Boltzmann
equation you want to make it something
go backwards just spin around and all
this and if you had color cycling on a
fractal you could do the turntable back
spin and the color cycling would reverse
and abundance of some of the things
we're working on right now we're just
gonna give you a little demo is there
anything any more slides on this part so
that was the end of the top part i'm
going to talk about and then we're going
to do a little demo for about a minute
and then Tom will talk about how he
worked with me to engineer some of this
so we're going to just we have to switch
something for a second okay there we go
so that sometimes mando i'm using a
little mixer thing here and we gotta
talk box over here when Tom brings the
second window over which he's got up on
the screens bring it over now and on
like we said this is a XY grid usually
it's centered because um we're not used
to this on the screen but if you can see
this on its grid we can move the
function on here and actually if I turn
this up especially
one two one two return low and when we
press the buttons up here we can get
different ones that we've on programmed
is not looking centered like we wanted
to but um okay yeah I can overlay it
over here we've also got on Steve we got
some videos of um he's got ca's loaded
up there and on over here let's see
we've got we've got on Conrad Wolfram
and programs now produce really nice
colorful real dope in this case is
program code real dope of real dope dope
about the words of this program code the
percent
that was an example of then he thought
about 50 cent on absolutely you know
competitions that involved you know
money 7 the way we're going rather than
selling better so that these things are
playing rapping it's okay absolute power
50 cent so that was an example of you
know we have pretty good systems
epiphany so he said picking 50 cent
instead of Dave's you know money seven
the road we're at one second good so
that those things where we have to be
careful isn't it new knowledge in and
that's still he's talking about arm you
haven't talked about 50 cent for a
second arm is anybody hood no um busy
something god unplug second Tommy you
like to talk my second while i plug this
in oh sure um yeah my name is Thomas
carpenter I work with Daniel Reynolds
I'm a software engineer a private
contractor and I've been interested in
Mathematica for some time I initially
had my experience in the 1990s and then
got interested in march of this year
we've been talking about interfacing
Mathematica with real-world sensors and
I've been interested in the Wolfram
devices but more than that we are kind
of interested in doing an artistic
interpretation of the data as it comes
in not a precise your usage that fits
within certain bounds but things that
will modify exponents on surfaces or
coefficients or various other parameters
their rotation but I'll get into it in
more detail as soon as he is finished
read open space this program code so
that those things where you have to be
careful as you knit new knowledge in
okay okay we're interested in connecting
Mathematica visualizations to external
data for art in for study okay can
everybody hear me okay very good and
here's the beginning of the slide show
and what you can do to intercept real
data and display it is to use a simple
manipulate and right here you see
something that I'm not sure that I can
display full screen but oh boy
okay if you'll give me a second I have
something running in the background in
this thing yeah well please yeah okay
here is here is a manipulate and
depending upon the whims of your
clicking and dragging you can change how
various parameters on this on this
function are affected and what we would
really like to do is to take the data
from the real world into you know
perhaps in this particular application
we're using MIDI data and we're
generating it from a synthesizer and
we're taking it into mathematica and
basically we have to have a connection
between the MIDI data and the
Mathematica program and what I use is
Jay link and I actually have a Java
program that connects to the USB and
pulls in this data and massages the data
and then presents it in public variables
to Mathematica and when i run the
visualization in Mathematica I can move
my finger on the chaos later the
synthesizer here and get show the
results
so in the process that I use is simply
to connect the synthesizer to the
computers the USB port and then I write
a Java program to read that port and
prepare the incoming data stream for
Mathematica and if any of you know Java
there is a very nice MIDI package that
can connect to various ports and receive
life data and manipulate that data into
various forms that's what i use in java
the java f java x javac sound midi
package I normalized that data that I
get in so that I can use it within the
bounds of zero to a hundred on a 2d
slider in Mathematica but I do this in
Java because the interpreted nature of
Mathematica would slow down the
visualization and produce a lot of lag
if i did it with in Mathematica so I
hand off that normalization and you know
data formatting job to Java and I embed
the Java program into mathematica Fiat
j-link so yeah that's basically what I
do and within the mathematica source
code I have various variables that are
named the same as those in the Java
program and I basically access the
object returned from the Java program
and place those variables into lightning
variables in Mathematica and I make the
variables in Mathematica dynamic so that
they update wherever they are used
within the notebook to give you an idea
of how the Java code looks I've
highlighted here and you can look at
this notebook at your leisure my
comments on for instance loading in the
Java sound midi file and how i use it in
how I loop through and look for the
various devices that are connected and
how a sign various parameters from the
MIDI stream two variables in Java and I
declare them public in the class so that
they be accessible through J lake the
mathematica code is kind of interesting
right here at the very top I i specify
that I need Jay link and then I specify
a long path you can see where i have the
java classes and that basically exposes
the api of my program to Mathematica to
this particular notebook all of these
variables here are local variables to
the notebook but later on you see I have
them set up as dynamics in the code so
that they can be used in my various
plots later on like right down here I
actually read in the data from the Java
object and assigned it to the
mathematica variable which is made
dynamics so it changes throughout the
application there are a lot of little
details to what I did here to make it
work for various devices here but I
won't get into them now this right here
is a function that basically operates
differently depending upon what button
you press on the synthesizer you can
display five or six different functions
what I hope to do is to have each of
these buttons display a class of
functions you know like linear
polynomial functions trigonometric
functions for one various classes of
cellular automata and then you would
turn a dial on the synthesizer and you
would get various instances various
kinds of functions like maybe a hundred
for each and there are a few things that
I would like to do besides that to
improve this application like what I
just mentioned up above number of the
first bullet the dials on the
synthesizer could also rotate a plot
and there also is you know depending
upon the function that I'm using you
notice the cellular automata and our
demo flicked by very rapidly but the
hyperbolic paraboloid with trig
functions had a little bit of a delay
well that could be solved by means of
taking several still shots of the
particular plot for where you want where
your range is you know on that on the
touchpad on the synthesizer and then
interpolated and you can use something
called B spline to do that or B spline
graphical and i hope to be building that
ensued the last bulleted area is
something that I'm aggressively working
on and that is to take real life signals
some noisy signals from a speaker or
microphone in decomposing them using a
Fourier analysis or a wavelet analysis
possibly first for the fast Fourier
analysis and then we could have plots
and in different objects moving in
accordance with changes in melody and
changes in rhythm and that would be very
exciting because we could use that kind
of analysis to manipulate and provide
feedback for let's say a microscopic
image of a Paramecium moving across a
field of vision for instance affecting
background tessellations and fractals or
whatever as it moves and the patterns
that result from this natural feedback
might be very interesting in themselves
not just for entertainment purposes so
let's see do I have anything else that
is basically what I want to cover does
anybody have any questions about the
programming involved
and like Tom said you can load the
different on types like in load cas and
start by pressing the buttons on the top
and like for example you have eight
slots we were looking at in like the UM
the Geo Metro zation conjecture there's
eight kinds of on 323 manifold so you
could load them onto eight buttons and
then by turning knobs you could you
could um you know transform those
manifolds and and use some differential
geometry and stuff that's the type of
thing that we're looking at and we've
only been doing this for a couple months
so like in about a year or two you know
this is going to be a lot bigger system
um since it's getting late we could you
know we could show you another time or
something more like is this um it's just
moving it okay as you see it moving
while I just show you one last thing to
make it make it funky hello 11 11 11
so if 110 shader here we go straight
down we'll see the right volume
[Music]
wah-wah-wah wah-wah-whoo okay thank you
that's the end